bonsoir et bienvenue pour le 7-8
nouvelle édition en direct si vous nous
rejoignez à 18 heures en ce 17 décembre
une heure pour faire le point sur
l'actualité locale élue dei qui
s'apprête à être officiellement lancés
dans les yvelines ce sera demain soir
depuis les clayes-sous-bois invités
notamment ce soir arnaud richard le
député de la 7e circonscription
le coordinateur du mouvement dans le
département dans une vingtaine de
minutes nous feront aussi le point sur
le sport avec anthony rech bonsoir
anthony bonsoir wilfried pour cette
toute dernière chronique de l'année 2012
je recevrai le président du tout nouveau
club de vélo d'elancourt saint quentin
en yvelines mais aussi les féminines de
l'entente le chesnay-versailles les
joueuses de vinko berdych viennent de
réaliser tout simplement une première
partie de saison quasi parfaite
nous essaierons d'expliquer les raisons
de ce succès et puis comme d'habitude en
fin de chronique tous les résultats du
week-end rendez-vous dans une vingtaine
de minutes anthony pour débuté voici les
titres de ce 17 décembre en images les
autres sujets qui vont être développés
dans cette édition et les villes ont
l'obligation avant le 31 décembre de se
regrouper entre elles un schéma de
coopération intercommunale a été arrêté
il fixe les périmètres de ces nouvelles
communautés de l'agglomération pas de
grandes modifications à attendre est la
fête des lumières où anouk à cette fête
juive a été célébré comme tous les ans à
montigny le bretonneux en présence cette
année de samuel sandler le rabbin de
versailles durement touchée par la
tuerie et de toulouse
la paire dans son fils et ses deux
petits-enfants
en football américain les templiers
d'elancourt ne reprendront pas à leur
saison avant la mi-février l'heure est
aux matches amicaux et à la préparation
pour les joueurs saint quentinois qui
évoluent dans le championnat élite la
plus haute division et ont volé en
régionale une masculine les joueurs de
montigny affrontés dans leur gymnase
l'équipe leader du championnat plaisir
logiquement le masi ni mon teint se sont
inclinées 3 sets à 1 la communauté juive
a donc célébré hanouka comme chaque
année les représentants du mouvement
loubavitch ont voulu associer le public
et c'est dans les rues de saint quentin
en yvelines que l'une des bougies de la
menora a été allumée jeudi soir
reportage à valérie auribeau alice
gastines et le dis moi
ce char
et
les participants frappé dans leurs mains
pour se réchauffer et fêter rannou qu'à
la fête des lumières symbole pour la
communauté juive de la lumière sur
l'obscurité ils étaient environ 70
personnes jeudi soir dans le quartier de
la gare de montigny le bretonneux pour
ce rassemblement historique
la fête des lumières est né dans
l'antiquité sous alexandre le grand
jérusalem est alors occupée et se voient
imposer la culture grecque
après avoir résisté la communauté juive
sous et rallumer le chandelier à sept
branches symbole de la lumière divine
dans ce milieu c'est important pour moi
d'être ici parce que c'est une fête qui
est quand même très très importante dans
la communauté juive
c'est la fête des lumières donc voilà
c'est aussi pour le rassemblement on se
retrouve tous un petit peu ici parce que
avec les vie privée de chacun et les
horaires de chacun sait pas forcément
facile de voir la lumière l'emportent
toujours l'oppression l'intolérance ne
peut pas vaincre
c'est au contraire cette volonté de
rester soi-même dans la fraternité dans
l'harmonie avec les autres qui lumbres
qui l'emportent
et c'est justement ce que veulent dire
ces flammes et ses lumières qu'on allume
la nuit une lueur d'espoir qui
espéraient également transmettre samuel
sandler dont le fils et les deux petits
enfants sont morts dans la tuerie de
toulouse perpétrés par mohamed merah en
mars 2012 dans la pensée juive
l'inestimable valeur de la vie
c'est pour donner aussi grâce à la
déclaration si souvent reprise
d'intérêts pro philosophe français
l'enfer c'est les autres
la pensée juive leur sail inverse à
savoir c'est le fait d'être privé de
tout moyen de prodiguer quoi que ce soit
aux autres qui s'assimile au pire des
supplices des mots issus du livre de son
fils jonathan
pour plus de mini lui d y prend ses
marques dans le département des yvelines
arnaud richard bonsoir vous êtes le
coordinateur sur le secteur des yvelines
demain 18 décembre à l'espace philippe
noiret c'est aux clayes-sous-bois le
mouvement lui dis lui des il sera
officiellement lancée
l'union des démocrates et indépendants
qui a été fondé le 18 septembre au
niveau national de cette année par jean
louis borloo
comment se porte lui dis lui dei dans le
département des yvelines
si le bébé va bien c'est assez récent 18
septembre
c'est une des premières pousses mais
c'est le 21 octobre à la mutualité qu'
il ya eu un rassemblement très populaire
qui a donné le déclenchement de cette
belle aventure auquel plus grand monde
ne croyait arriver à rassembler
l'ensemble des familles centriste eh
bien on est arrivé au tour de jean louis
borloo avec vraiment la volonté de
mettre en place un parti indépendant
libre avec ses propres valeurs et ses
propres idées donc là on est demain sur
la mise sur les fonts baptismaux dans
les yvelines
une première réunion qui on a même dû
bouchra sur d'autres aux quatre coins du
département
vous êtes député déi vous êtes élu
depuis 2010 mais à l'époque c'était pas
forcément société ludier il n'existait
pas c'était un petit peu compliqué je
précise que vous êtes d'ailleurs l'un
des plus jeunes députés français ou
moins jeunes que dans la précédente
mandature mais toujours l'un des plus
jeunes lui dis donc se fait entendre
dans l'assemblée nationale et cela plaît
beaucoup parce que c'est ça le socle de
l'idc modestie d'abord parce que l'ump
est un peu dans des situations
difficiles ce qui fait que l'ump
partager mais ça c'est pas satisfaisant
et je pense que on en sortira assez vite
mais lui se fait très entendre parce que
nous avons surtout les textes récents le
budget le budget de la sécu les emplois
d'avenir
nous avons des positions très
volontaires qui peuvent être positives
on a voté le texte sur les emplois
d'avenir on verra ce qu'on fera sur le
contrat de génération justement ça va à
l'encontre de ce que fait l'ump quelle
position par rapport à lever les mains
vous l'avions précisé que si le texte
est bon
si le texte des mots il ya perdu donc
pas le voter donc comme sur les contrats
d'avenir par exemple où les emplois des
voeux groupe udc a voté pour c'est
exactement le texte n'était pas fameux
en arrivant le texte du gouvernement
mais avec les autres groupes du
d'assemblée on a amélioré le sénat
également il ya mis sa touche et nous on
a considéré à la fin du dispositif que
le texte était bon
en toute simplicité partout le mans le
texte et vous il ya pas d onde pas le
voter alors tel positionnement par
rapport à l'ump
havas l'ump est notre allié
véritablement notre allié naturel notre
partenaire il n'y a pas d'angoissé on
sait où sont nos alliances mais s'ils
n'empêchent pas quand un texte à
l'assemblée ou au sénat est bon de le
voter
j'ai pu me permettre vous avez vu qu'au
sénat la majorité est un peu plus
compliqué donc nous on considère que
c'est tout à fait normal de voter un
texte il est bon que pensez vous de la
création de l'udps et nous avons posé la
question dans les rues des yvelines
justement je vous laisse écouter mais on
a l'impression d'assister à quelque part
la recomposition un peu de l'udf ou
partie du golfe on sait pas bien si
c'est du df ou si c'est un jeu politique
plus complexe à ne sais quoi lui laisser
les c'est en fait c'est les centristes
qui sont tous remis ensemble
suite à la déroute de l'ump c'est ça
hein les rats ont quitté le navire c'est
toujours ça le sens finalement c'est
plutôt ouais c'est borloo c'est pas que
j'aime pas mais je trouve qu'il n'est
pas hélas pas la stature d'un homme
politique
il est sympathique à côté c'est quand
même super bien tomber quand même une
grosse crise à l'ump et à bastien venez
mes frères de valeur
et puis quant à lui des ics est ce que
je dirais d'autres je dirais que c'est
un parti centriste mais le centre et la
droite donc
voilà c'est rien de nouveau sous le
soleil voilà quelques réactions je vais
vous laisser réagir tout de même on a
entendu les rats ont quitté le navire à
l'ump pour fonder lui n'est alors pas du
tout d'abord parce que la démarche de
lui dit elle a commencé déjà il ya
plusieurs - avec l'arrêt ce qui lui n'a
pas continué mais donc on n'a vraiment
pas attendu la crise à l'ump pour créer
le deuil et le mettre sur les fonts
baptismaux ça se fait déjà depuis
plusieurs mois déjà
à l'arrivée à l'assemblée on s'est tous
mis dans un groupe id qui compte
aujourd'hui trente parlementaires
donc évidemment je suis désolé pour ce
monsieur qui en l'occurrence a raison en
disant que lui des lycées centres
c'est le centre et la droite évidemment
nous allions sont très claires je sens
que c'est la droite c'est le centre et
la droite c'est ce que je voulais vous
dire mais nous n'avons évidemment pas
attendu ce qui arrive à l'ump pour créer
du diy loin de là elle udi donc c'est
plusieurs parties qui gardent leur
existence un d'ailleurs partie fécales
le nouveau centre l'alliance centriste
le centre national des indépendants et
paysans notamment s'est pas trop
difficile justement de fédérer tous
m'ont écouté ses six parties vous avez
oublié l'alliance centriste
hélas la fed c'est vrai que chacun son
identité ce qui est très bien mais je
crois que on est en train de construire
quelque chose de difficile donc si
c'était difficile s'il fallait arrêter
parce que c'est difficile de sa serait
pas intéressant la politique je crois
que c'est justement parce que on a tous
aussi cette identité de centristes que
c'est passionnant avec eux dans les
yvelines des tempéraments très fort et
je m'engagerai un creux est un
coordinateur ce qui n'est pas simple le
plus juste possible
mais du fait de la crise à l'ump est ce
que justement des anciens l'ump viennent
vous voir en tout cas s'intéresse un peu
plus à ce qui se passe du côté de lui
des ide en les aimer une par exemple
s'intéresse oui parce que celles et ceux
qui sont soit militants sur les lui
s'intéresse à la pluie digne on
s'intéresse toujours à ce qui se passe
là plaisir face à lc intéressait aussi
on peut aussi les montagnes vers un
intérêt assez vif d'un certain nombre
d'élus qui soit n'ont pas d'étiquette
politique ou pas de carte soit peuvent
avoir un engagement à droite donc
effectivement mais les gens sont aussi
en observation de la manière dont nous
allons mettre les choses en place et de
la manière dont lui dit va se mettre en
place dans les yvelines donc l'idée
c'est de faire de lui dès la première
force politique d'opposition
ça c'est l'engagement qu'a pris jean
louis borloo avec l'idée d'avoir cent
mille adhérents l'an prochain et il
150000 à la proche des élections
européennes ce qui est ce un challenge
très fort puisque historiquement les
partis du centre n'était pas des partis
de masse
donc voilà on ne serait pas à la hauteur
de l'ump ou du parti socialiste mais ça
commence à faire du mas si on arrive à
un tel niveau d'adhérence et je reviens
juste un tout petit peu en arrière sur
le micro trottoir parce que je vous ai
pas fait réagir tout à l'heure les
délices et la nouvelle udf
non lui dit c'est pas la nouvelle udf ou
alors si c'est la nouvelle udf c'est
l'udf du 21e siècle
on est donc bon voilà donc je crois pas
qu'il faut comparer ce qui est pas on
n'est pas dans la même tendance l'udf a
été créé et est pour d'autres raisons
là il y avait une soif et non vie soit
de faire apparaître de nouveaux talents
on soit de concentrer autour d'une d'une
même identité des valeurs et des idées
que l'on partage
on va vous montrer quelques photos
arnaud richard et puis je vais vous
laisser les commenté me dire ce que vous
pensez des personnalités politiques qui
y figurent première photo photo de jean
louis borloo
le fondateur donc de lui des abats à
l'inversé de ce qu'a pu penser cette
dame 1 à mon sens un homme d'état que
vous avez entendu tout à l'heure
effectivement dans le micro trottoir on
entendait il n'a pas la carrure pour
vous il a la carrure georges gt gt sept
ans son collaborateur
c'est difficile de pas dire qu'il a pas
la carrure en tout cas je les vous avez
travaillé au sein de son cabinet j'ai vu
passer deux derniers ministres du
gouvernement à numéro deux donc c'est
une évolution politique est assez rare
je pense qu'il a la carrure d'homme
d'état oui seconde photo photo de france
1 0
françois bayroux je pense qu'il a eu
peut-être raison avant tout le monde ça
il faut lui rendre hommage
maintenant son positionnement n'est pas
simple la porte est ouverte pour le
modem
on s'adapte a toujours été ouverte à lui
dit pour les gens qui partagent nos
valeurs je crois pluie et pas très à
l'aise par rapport à la réussite qui a
été de la note de crédit
parce que si on cite par exemple bruno
tarricq est le chef de file du modem
dans le département des yvelines lui
nous précise qu'il ne souhaite pas
rejoindre en tout cas lui dit qu'il
reste président du modem dans le
département des yvelines derrière donc
françois bayrou quelles différences
d'ailleurs entre le modèle et lui dit
pendant le blitz il fallait faire une
différence au moment des élections par
exemple comment vous allez faire la
différence entre ces deux mouvements
centristes jeudi je pense que je pense
que françois bayrou en 2007
prenez cette voie un peu d'alternatives
il avait certainement raison trop tôt
aujourd'hui ne pas rejoindre l'ue des
hymnes pari un peu risqué pour lui pour
vous l'avenir v120 de passe par lui même
si c'est du centre droit du swing roissy
il faut bien de préciser qui ait pas
d'ambiguïté par rapport au modèle ou la
position était un petit peu un petit peu
plus large on l'a vu avec ces dernières
élections présidentielles notamment
on en revient à nos différentes photos
si on peut afficher la troisième photo
celle d'un représentant de l'ump ce
n'est pas la photo c'est toujours
françois bayrou mais voilà pour cette
photo celle de françois fillon dit
françois fillon étaient cinq en premier
ni ça a été un grand premier ministre
aujourd'hui ils essayent avec certains
noms de personnalités comme françois
copé jean-françois copé de bâtir
l'avenir du de l'ump je trouve que
l'exercice est difficile j'avais un mot
pour le résumer il est assez sage sage
c'est le mot pour définir françois
fillon est alors le mot pour définir
forcément jean françois copé alors jean
françois copé est peut-être un peu moins
sage il est surtout extrêmement
volontariste extrêmement volontariste
vous vous retrouvez le plus dans lequel
des deux personnages
moi je ne peux pas prendre de répondre à
ce genre de questions parce que
lequel sera le bienvenu à lui dénient
par exemple je crois que ni l'un ni
l'autre n'en auront envie de nous
rejoindre mais ils seraient les
bienvenus les deux crois que chacun a
son chemin son histoire françois fillon
était un très grand parlementaire un
très grand premier ministre jean
françois copé est sur la voie ascendante
moi j'ai d'excellents rapports avec les
deux ils ont chacun leur tempérament et
leur place dans la vie politique
française lui dénier officiellement
lancée dans le département des yvelines
demain on en parlait tout à l'heure
c'est une mise en route véritablement
pour les élections de 2014 mars
oui ça c'est la ligne de mire mais comme
tous les partis on est intéressé par ce
qui se passe au projet de sélection
surtout que c'est une élection qui
vraiment dans les territoires dans les
communes et c'est vraiment la
quintessence de l'histoire du monde
centriste donc on sera très très à
l'affût de faire mettre en valeur nos
nos idées et ceux qui les portent dans
les élections municipales concernant les
municipales lui d y sera présente
partout dans le département des yvelines
parce qu'il ne s'agit pas d'être présent
partout pour être présent j'ai les idées
de présents avec des candidats de
qualité qui puisse porter haut et fort
nos valeurs je n'aime pas faire c'est
bien ça y est en tête on n'est pas dans
la politique du chiffre
mais à moins de larmes qui vous
intéresse peut-être aussi d'économie qui
nous intéresse mais il serait trop tôt
pour en parler mais on aura l'occasion
d'en parler j'espère qu'à cette occasion
vous reviendrez bien évidemment sur sur
le sur le plateau sk des accords déjà
qui se négocie avec l'ump même si on
imagine l'ump a d'autres chats à
fouetter actuellement mais il ya des
discussions
la réponse est dans votre question voilà
mais pour autant vous avez commencé à
discuter pour autant on discute après
c'est pas qu'une histoire de prendre des
villes il s'agit surtout de pouvoir
avoir les hommes et les femmes et les
nouveaux talents et les nouveaux visages
qui puisse défendre nos valeurs et si
telle ou telle commune et ils sont là on
négociera âprement avec nos partenaires
naturels qui l'ump de questions pour
terminer centriste aujourd'hui ça
signifie croire
je crois que c'est une sensibilité
particulière d'abord à ces humanistes
s'est tourné vers la société et sa
dimension sociale et puis c'est aussi un
projet européen que sur lequel nous
sommes tous d'accord ce qui n'est pas le
cas de beaucoup de parties sur
l'échiquier politique
et puis la dernière question pour
résumer lui dit comment vous pourriez
résumé lui dénient sur quelle base elle
s'est construite je crois que sur les
sur les idées et les valeurs
ce qu'on pouvait lire aussi notamment
dans les différentes analyses étaient
que l'udps est regroupé plutôt ceux qui
refusaient la droitisation de l'ump
vous partagez très certainement le
positionnement qui est nôtre est au
centre à la droite et au centre donc
effectivement un certain nombre de
propos peut être un peu malheureux ou
interprétés comme étant malheureux n'ont
pas plu à beaucoup de gens qui sont dans
nos rangs oui merci à nos arnaud richard
députée donc de cette 7e circonscription
des yvelines je rappelle lancement
officiel de l'ue dei demain 18 décembre
clayes sous bois